charlotte à tort son nouveau manteau à
la fin de l'hiver fait nettoyer quand
elle va le chercher
rien ne va plus le capuchon et déchiré
et l'intérieur en duvet tout déformé
formant tonique plus portable de
nettoyeurs l'offre dédommagement 50
dollars charlotte se dit ça ne suffit
pas
ce manteau à côté des centaines de
dollars elle demande au nettoyeur de lui
rembourser son montant at-elle raison
oui le nettoyeur devait lui redonner son
manteau propres et en bon état
comme il ne l'a pas fait il doit la
dédommager toutefois charlotte a porté
son manteau tout l'hiver le nettoyeur de
nous soustraire une somme équivalant à
la dépréciation du manteau le fin mot de
l'histoire
s'il nettoyeur à bien votre m'entourent
préférées il ne doit pas tenter de vous
lessivé